no era el plan que tenía en mente pero
los informes sobre una gestión tóxica y
las denuncias de acoso sexual le
expulsaron de lo que se conoce como las
tres F obligado a dimitir el 11 de enero
Noel logreta tirado la toalla después de
meses de presiones de declaraciones de
la ministra de deportes y de una
reacción generalizada contra su
Providencia
truncando un cuarto mandato que le
habría permitido seguir al frente de la
federación francesa de fútbol hasta 2024
le sustituirá temporalmente el
vicepresidente Philip dialou hasta la
celebración de nuevas elecciones en
junio
lo que deseo es que la federación
continúe su proceso de modernización que
el comportamiento en sus senos sea
irreprochable y su actitud ejemplar
y también que sea más democrática vamos
a reformar algunos cargos en los
próximos meses
pero aunque la dimisión de él parte del
foco mediático los problemas no
desaparecen la fiscalía de París ha
abierto una investigación sobre las
acusaciones de intimidación y acoso
sexual que el expresidente niega
Mientras tanto se espera que flojas la
directora general se ha despedida en
breve ya que las intenciones de reformar
la organización marcaría en el final de
los once años de reinado de lograr